He is the most bankable star in Hollywood
– an action hero with a massive, ripped
physique who has impeccable comedic timing
and a never ending supply of charm.
He is also one of the greatest wrestling superstars
to ever emerge from the stables of the WWE
and the only third generation wrestling star
in history.
The story of Dwayne Johnson – the Rock – is
a tale of dedication, grit and old fashioned
hard work.
In this week’s Biographics we chart the
rise and rise of 2016’s Sexiest Man Alive
– Dwayne Johnson.
Formative Years
Dwayne Douglas Johnson was born on May 2nd,
1972 in Hayward County, California.
His mother Ata was of Samoan origin, while
his father, Wayde, was a Black Nova Scotian.
Wayde earned his living as a professional
wrestler under the name of ‘Rocky Johnson’.
To further entrench the wrestling gene in
his blood, Dwayne’s material grandfather
had also been a professional wrestler.
Promoted as High Chief Peter Maivia, he was
the first Samoan wrestler to break into the
big time.
A generation later, Rocky became the first
black champion to conquer the state wrestling
scene.
Rocky hustled as a wrestler, taking on bouts
wherever he could in order to support his
family.
Times were tough with the family moving from
state to state to keep pace with the wrestling
venues.
In fact, during Dwayne’s formative years,
the family of three lived in 38 of the 50
states as they became entrenched in the gypsy
wrestling lifestyle.
The only time Dwayne got to see his dad was
when he went on the road with him.
He cherished these times and quickly fell
in love with everything to do with professional
wrestling.
His dad taught him some basic moves, including
the sleeper hold.
When he was eleven, Dwayne was ‘playing’
wrestling one school lunchtime when he put
the sleeper hold on a schoolmate.
The kid immediately passed out.
Unfortunately, Rocky hadn’t shown his son
how to bring someone out of the sleeper hold.
The ambulance and the police were called and
Rocky had to come down to revive the student.
The Johnson house became a hangout for Dwayne’s
school-mates, who knew that they were going
to have to go several rounds with their host.
Dwayne would turn these events into mock TV
shows, where he would pretend to interview
the wrestlers.
He would even interview himself as he portrayed
the bad guy.
His showmanship was immediately evident as
he came out with all sorts of outrageous pronouncements
against his intended victims.
Dwayne excelled in a number of sports.
Physically he was miles ahead of his classmates.
He had his first weights workout when he was
thirteen, but he’d been tagging along with
his dad to the gym since he was 5 years old.
As he sat quietly on a bench and watched proudly
as Rocky pounded out set after set with gargantuan
weights, Dwayne breathed in the gym atmosphere
and marvelled at the sight of huge men doing
seemingly impossible things with massive loads
of iron.
While other dads took their kids to the playground,
Rocky took Dwayne to some of the most hardcore
gyms in the country.
It was here that the future superstar learned
that there was no replacement for pure, gut
wrenching hard work.
A Love Affair with Iron is Born
At the age of eight, Rocky allowed Dwayne
to participate in sports.
He tried baseball, soccer, martial arts and
gymnastics.
What he was really longing to do was to start
lifting weights, but he’d have to wait a
few more years for that.
Finally, on his 13th birthday, his dad took
him to a local gym for his first ever weights
workout.
An obvious place to start was the bench press,
which he’d studied for years as his dad
and others pressed massive amounts of steel
from their chest.
Rocky had his son start with an unloaded bar.
He pumped out 10 reps with no problem, so
Rocky added a 20-pound plate to each end.
This time Dwayne pushed out 8 easy reps.
Impressed, Rocky asked his son if he wanted
to try the 45 pounders.
Dwayne nodded his head.
His dad stood behind him and lifted the bar
off the supports – and Dwayne got buried
under the 135-pound weight.
He felt embarrassed and ashamed – as if
he had let his dad down.
That feeling fuelled an intense desire to
get better at the bench press and within a
few years he would be bench pressing 400 pounds.
Between the ages of 14 and 15, Dwayne excelled
in the gym.
By the time he entered high school he had
grown to a towering 6 foot 3 inches and tipped
the scales at 225 pounds.
His imposing physicality gave him a great
deal of self-confidence, which sometimes bordered
on arrogance.
Eve though he had developed a healthy dose
of self-discipline in the gym, his unstable
home life, that saw his father constantly
travelling, left him directionless when he
wasn’t pounding the weights.
As a result, he started getting into trouble.
It came to a head when he was fifteen and
got arrested for check fraud.
His parents had to come to collect him from
the place station.
When he looked at his mother and father he
realized that, despite living from paycheck
to paycheck, he was the biggest source of
stress in their lives.
In that moment he vowed that he would never
cause problems for his folks again.
Although that was the last time Dwayne got
arrested, it wasn’t the last time he caused
worry for Rocky and Ata.
In fact, the very next day at school he got
into a fight and knocked the other kid out.
It earned him a two-week suspension.
Upon returning to school he decided that the
student’s bathroom was not good enough for
him and so he decided to use the teacher’s
one.
When asked to leave he was rude to the teacher
and tried to intimidate him with his physical
presence.
That night Dwayne felt pangs of guilt at the
way he had treated the teacher.
So, the next day, he marched into the teacher’s
class and holding out his hand, said that
he wanted to apologise for the way he had
acted the day before.
The teacher stared at Dwayne’s hand for
a moment then grabbed it and told Dwayne that
he appreciated the apology.
Then, still holding the boy’s hand, he said.
“I want you to play football for me.”
Football Star
Football proved to be a positive outlet for
Dwayne’s frustrations and aggressions, providing
him with a renewed sense of focus.
Under the watchful eye of coach Jody Cwick,
he steadily improved, both as a student and
as an athlete.
By the time he was a high school senior he
was ranked as one of the top 10 defensive
tackles in the country and was offered a scholarship
to the University of Miami, the No.1 college
team in the United States.
At Miami, Dwayne’s combination of size,
strength and athleticism coupled with his
strong work ethic made him a standout from
the very beginning.
Practices were going great and he was primed
to be the only freshman to play on the Varsity
team.
But then tragedy struck.
On the last day of practice with pads, he
crashed to the ground under the full weight
of his shoulder.
It was dislocated and a number of ligaments
were torn.
That night he had reconstruction surgery and
was told that he’d need a year to recover.
He was put before the season had even begun.
Dwayne fell into a deep depression, not even
bothering to go to class.
Then, without even attempting any of his mid-terms,
he hopped on a flight and returned home, which
at that time was in Tampa, Florida.
After a couple of weeks he got a call from
Miami’s head coach, Dennis Erickson.
He told Dwayne that he wanted him back at
school in two days.
He wanted to talk to him.
When they met up, Erickson was furious with
Johnson.
He told him that he had embarrassed himself
and the team.
Erickson had trusted him with a position of
responsibility and leadership and he had completely
let him down.
Erickson then placed Dwayne under academic
probation.
He was to attend every class, every practice
and every game – sitting on the sideline.
However, to get into daily practice he had
to get the signatures of every one of his
professors attesting that he had been to class
that day.
If he didn’t, he would lose his scholarship.
Dwayne dug deep and did what had to be done.
He eventually became academic captain and
in his junior year was pre-season All-American.
He graduated from Miami University in 1995
with a Bachelor of General Studies in criminology
and physiology.
It was at the University of Miami that Dwayne
met Dany Garcia, his future wife.
They were married in 1997 and divorced 10
years later.
After a year’s injury recovery, Dwayne wasn’t
quite a fast or as mobile on the football
field.
He was circuit from the team and replaced
by Warren Sapp.
After graduation from Miami Dwayne went to
Calgary, Canada as a practice squad player
for the Stampeders.
Things were tough for him in Canada.
He had hardly any money and few prospects.
But things got worse when he was cut from
the Stampeders squad after just two months.
A Wrestler Like His Dad
Arriving back at his parents’ tiny apartment
in Tampa, Dwayne was now at rock bottom.
His football career was effectively over.
He needed to look in another direction.
He dug deep and realized that all of his life
his passion had been professional wrestling.
If he never turned his hand to it, he would
forever be unfulfilled.
And if he was going to step into that world,
now was the time.
His mother and girlfriend encouraged him to
go for it, but Dwayne’s dad had major reservations.
Rocky knew firsthand just how tough the life
of a wrestler was and he wanted more for his
son.
Yet, he vowed to stand behind his son, so
long as he put 11% effort into becoming successful.
Rocky now became Dwayne’s full-time wrestling
coach.
From the start, though, he taught him much
more than wrestling moves.
He taught him how to be a showman.
After a few months of intensive work, Rocky
felt his son was ready to take the next step.
He got in touch with a former wrestler named
Pat Patterson who was now a talent agent.
Patterson came to check out what Dwayne looked
like in the ring.
Impressed he arranged for a signing with the
WWE.
Dwayne was put into the minor leagues and
was given the name ‘Rocky Maivia’ in homage
to both his father and grandfather.
He started wrestling in small arenas for $20
a pop, but it didn’t take long before he
got his break.
The 1996 WWE Survivor series was televised
live on TV from Madison Square Garden – and
the new kid on the block was ‘Rocky Maivia.’
He made an immediate impression, establishing
himself as a rising WWE star by becoming the
last man standing.
Rocky Maivia took on a charismatic, in your
face persona which proved to be too loud and
arrogant for many diehard WWE fans.
His character was rejected for being too tacky
and fans came to see Rocky Maivia as an extremely
unlikeable character.
When he wrestled the stadium would be littered
with signs reading ‘Rocky Sucks’ and ‘Die
Rocky, Die.’
But his perseverance and the constant refining
of his character eventually won the fans over.
Fans came to appreciate that Rocky’s narcissism
was tongue in cheek, much in the mould of
Muhammad Ali and they began to enjoy his over
the top sense of humour.
When he shortened his name to ‘The Rock’,
the fans embraced it and, within a year, he
had transformed the wrestler everyone loved
to hate to the ‘people’s champ.’
Dominating the WWE
Throughout 1997 and 1998 the Rock had ongoing
battles with Stone Cold Steve Austin, Triple
H and Mankind.
Throughout 1999 the WWF championship belt
passed between The Rock and Mankind several
times during a series of epic encounters.
Then towards the end of ‘99, the two teamed
up to become the Rock ‘n Sock Connection
and going on to win the tag team championship
three times.
The Rock and Mankind also performed comedy
skits on WWE live telecasts.
One of them was a take-off of This is Your
Life in which Mankind interviewed people from
the Rock’s past.
The segment drew an 8.4 Nielsen rating, one
of the highest ever for a WWE segment.
In 2001, the Rock was suspended indefinitely
during the airing of Raw is War.
He used the suspension as an opportunity to
move into the acting arena.
Still, he would return again and again to
the wrestling ring.
In 2011 he was the host of Wrestlemania 2011.
He spent a large part of the promo build up
insulting and taunting John Cena, who he had
already been calling out on social media.
A feud developed between the two which continued
for another two years.
When he finally stepped away from the wrestling
ring in 2016 The Rock had established himself
as one of the great pro wrestlers of all time.
Hulk Hogan, himself a dominating WWE figure,
referred to him as ‘the biggest superstar
in the business’, a sentiment which was
echoed by John Cena.
One of his many catch-phrases, ‘lay the
smackdown’, inspired the title of television’s
second longest running TV series, Smackdown!
The Rock has also entrenched himself in the
WWE record books.
He was the first wrestler to win the WWF / WWE
championship seven times.
And his intercontinental championship reign
of 265 days is the longest in the modern era.
A New Career Beckons
Dwayne’s huge popularity as a WWE character
allowed him to cross over into mainstream
media.
His first acting job was in a 1999 episode
of That 70’s Show in which played his own
father.
In 2000, he appeared in Star Trek: Voyager
as an alien wrestler.
His first movie appearance was a small role
in 2001’s The Mummy Returns.
The movie was a smash hit, leading to a reprisal
of his role, this time as the lead, in The
Scorpion King.
Johnson was paid $5.5 million for the role,
earning him a spot in the Guinness Book of
Records as the highest paid actor in a debut,
despite it actually being his second movie.
The Scorpion King established Johnson as a
bona fide star.
With his comedic talents clearly established
through his wrestling career, his next film,
the action comedy The Rundown was a natural
next step.
This was followed up with a remake of the
true story of kick-ass sheriff Buford Pusser
in Walking Tall.
This role cemented Johnson’s position as
the ultimate hard as nails action hero with
a heart of gold.
Over the next few years, Dwayne skipped between
comedies and action movies with such films
as Be Cool, Doom, Tooth Fairy (a film which
was originally written for one of the Rock’s
heroes, Arnold Schwarzenegger) and The Fast
and The Furious franchise.
His debut in Fast and Furious came in the
fifth movie, after fans demanded to see a
showdown between Johnson and Vin Diesel.
The movie was the most successful in the entire
franchise, making more than $86 million on
its opening weekend.
This remains the biggest opening for any Johnson
movie.
Dwayne has interspersed his movie roles with
appearances on a number of TV shows, many
of them aimed at a pre-teen audience.
He appeared in episodes of Cory in the House
and The Wizards of Waverly Place and was the
host of the Nickelodeon Kid’s Choice Awards
in 2009.
That year he also appeared several times on
Saturday Night Live where he introduced his
Rock Obama character, a morphing of President
Obama with the Incredible Hulk.
Superstar
By the end of the 2000’s, Johnson had developed
a reputation as a bankable star who could
not only carry a new movie, but also had a
proven record of being able to revive franchises
that were getting tired.
He became known as a very busy actor, with
at least a couple of new movies coming out
each year.
In 2013, Johnson starred in a couple of true
life-based movie, Pain and Gain and Empire
State.
He also announced that year that he was to
executive produce and star in an HBO TV series
set in the world of professional football
called Ballers.
In December, 2013, Forbes magazine named Johnson
as the highest paid actor of the year, with
earnings of $1.3 billion.
Ballers, which debuted on HBO in June 2015,
proved to be a huge success.
Johnson, who plays Spencer Strathmore, a retired
NFL player who has gone on to a career as
a financial planner for current NFL players,
received props for his charm and depth.
As of 2018, the show is into its fourth season.
In 2014, Johnson played the title character
in Hercules.
For this role he stepped up his already gruelling
workout and nutrition protocol in order to
get as impressively muscular as possible.
He followed this up with the huge disaster
hit San Andreas, before switching back to
comedy with Central Intelligence, alongside
Kevin Hart.
2016 saw Johnson teaming with Zac Efron for
a feature movie version of the classic beach
and babes TV series Baywatch.
The two hulky actors created a lot of pre-release
buzz with their epic beach workouts in which
Johnson would present Efron with gut-busting
physical challenges.
The movie, however, was a box office disappointment.
Johnson finished out 2016 by learning that
he had been voted People Magazine’s Sexiest
Man Alive.
The next big project was a remake of the Robin
Williams classic Jumanji.
Johnson, along with co-stars Jack Black and
Kevin Hart, brought a new, updated angle to
the story that resonated with fans.
The movie has so far brought in $829 million
on a $90 million budget.
The Rock’s Anchor
Throughout his life Dwayne has had one constant
that has kept him grounded and which he credits
as the basis of everything that he has achieved;
the gym.
From those earliest days when he would sit
and watch his father dominate the weights
in the 1970’s, the sights, smells and sounds
of working out became an integral part of
his being.
Dwayne’s workout intensity and dedication
have been an inspiration to millions.
He hits the gym at 4 o’clock every morning,
training for up to 2 hours with heavy basic
compound moves, interspersed with cardio to
keep his body fat percentage into the single
digits.
He is a favourite with the bodybuilding community,
appearing as a guest host at the 2016 Mr.
Olympia competition.
Since 2014, Dwayne has been living in Southwest
Ranches in Florida.
His first child, Simone, was born in 2001,
while he was still married to her mother,
Dany.
In 2015 his second daughter, Jasmine was born
to his girlfriend of 9 years, Lauren Hashian.
Dwayne Johnson has risen from humble beginnings
to establish himself as the most bankable
movie star of the 21st century.
In the process he has brought back to mainstream
entertainment the sort of alpha male persona
that has been so absent for so long.
He has become
the people’s champion once again.